frau merkel ist gescheitert und es wird
zeit dass ich als bundeskanzler
wir finden es gut dass es nicht zur
jamaika koalition kommt denn das wäre
eine koalition gewesen nicht die
gesellschaftlichen wende nicht einer
anderen politik soll das wäre eine
koalition des weiter so gewesen und wir
sind froh dass die grünen keine
verantwortung über
das zumindest ist die chance dass über
familiennachzug vernünftig nachgedacht
wird das über die asylpolitik vernünftig
nachgedacht wird und dass der irrsinn
der immer toll wenn energiewende und das
sozusagen des allmählichen auslaufens
des verbrennungsmotors dass das jetzt
nicht politik wird insofern ist es gut
dass die grünen nicht mehr dabei sind
wir sind der meinung als partei dass es
eine bürgerliche mehrheit gibt dazu
müsste sich aber die cdu sehr ändern und
wir hoffen dass diese pleite von frau
merkel auch dazu führt dass in der cdu
um gedacht wird danke ja auch von meiner
seite erst mal guten morgen
was wir jetzt erlebt haben war eine
wochenlange wählertäuschung da sind
parteien ins rennen gegangen deren
wahlversprechen unterschiedlicher nicht
hätten sein können
man hat vorher gewusst dass man dort
keine einigung hätte erzielen können
ohne die eigenen wähler auch mit zu
verraten das haben wir jetzt gesehen
fast fünf wochen eine ergebnislose
verhandlung auf steuerzahlerkosten und
wir gauland schon gesagt hat merkel ist
gescheitert und wir sehen auch hier dass
die afg wirkt denn wir haben schwarz
grün verhindert das ist das klare
ergebnis hier und wir bereiten uns auf
eine vernünftige oppositionspartei im
bundestag vor wir freuen uns darauf und
wir freuen uns eben auch auf eventuelle
neuwahlen
vielen dank wollen sie neue ware zum
nächstmöglichen zeitpunkt
wir müssen wir erstmal die ganzen
entwicklung abwarten
das kann man jetzt ist es ist es viel zu
früh für eventuelle prognosen man hat
noch einige möglichkeiten aber wir
bereiten uns natürlich darauf fuhren wir
rotieren das auch
aber natürlich im moment können sie an
den umfragen sehen dazu steigen von
daher glauben wir dass das besser wäre
für uns aber da muss jetzt der
bundespräsident ins spiel kommen und das
hat jetzt keinen zweck hier über
neuwahlen zu spekulieren das liegt ja
nicht an uns noch ist sie nicht weg
deswegen kann ich am lindner im moment
nicht einfach sein aber es ist ein stück
erreicht und verweist schon völlig
richtig gesagt dass es kein schwarz-grün
gibt das ist der erfolg der afd denn das
wollte frau merkel eine schwarz-grüne
koalition die kann es nun nicht geben
und das ist gut so
schreiben
das ist eine konkurrenz partei das ist
eine partei die wie wir auch das erste
mal jetzt wieder im bundestag ist
mehr kann man dazu im moment nicht sagen
[Musik]
das glaube ich nicht
ja es ist richtig dass herr lindner auch
in seinen stellungnahmen heute morgen
den eindruck macht
er ist dicht an der afg an den
kritikpunkten der af die
flüchtlingspolitik rechtsstaat aber wir
sind das original und verweist schon
gesagt herr lindner hat lange versucht
ohne eine wende die jetzt an mahnt in
eine große koalition zu gehen
offensichtlich aber sind die zumutungen
der anderen so groß gewesen dass herr
lindner aus fdp interesse gesagt hat
nein das will ich dann doch nicht
aber deswegen ist er keineswegs
sozusagen die bessere eröffnet
die bessere 18 schuldig
[Gelächter]
naja herrn seehofer verstehe ich gar
nicht kenne
denn er hätte im grunde genommen die
notbremse ziehen müssen
denn wer ist ja jedenfalls verbal noch
stärker von den grünen entfernt als die
fdp aber er hat es offensichtlich nicht
gemacht ja was ich heute früh gehört es
sogar wir waren kurz vor einer einigung
wie man sich in der weise einigen will
auf der einen seite die csu ohne
familiennachzug auf der anderen seite
die grünen die am liebsten sozusagen das
ganze land mit vielen flüchtlingen
bevölkern wollen das kann ich mir
überhaupt nicht vorstellen
angenehm consolation finale
[Musik]
machen sie mit
die
dass du sie
nach 1 überhaupt nicht das sehe ich
überhaupt nicht im gegenteil ich sehe
dass wir wirken dass wir mit dem was wir
vertreten
sozusagen die anderen inzwischen gott
sei dank von dieser koalition weg
getrieben haben
seit kurzen die wahrscheinlich
das ist mir zu früh darüber zu
spekulieren
das muss die cdu jetzt für sich tun nein
das ist den anderen zu verdanken nicht
uns
sehr schwer zu sagen also ich halte mich
da jetzt ganz bewusst zurück weil wir
wirklich die entwicklung abwarten müssen
und es ist einfach wichtig dass die
wichtige position für unser land
eingehalten werden
wir kritisieren zu recht dass wir immer
noch offene grenzen haben
rechtswidrigkeiten weil der flüchtlings
auch bei der euro rettungspolitik und
wir machen eine gruppierung davon
abhängig welche position sich
letztendlich durchsetzen
und dafür ist es jetzt einfach zu früh
das dann parteien zu kennen wenn sie das
so positiv formulieren
dazu müssen sie doch noch große
positionen gucken genau das ist
eigentlich nicht das wäre ja furchtbar
für dieses land wenn die politik der
letzten legislatur fortgesetzt würde
auch dahingehend würde es mir für die
spd sehr leid tun die sich ja durch die
koalition mit merkel verstärkt hatte ich
denke dass auch die spd da die leeren
rausgezogen hat aber was noch sehr
interessant ist sich die csu auch im
vorlauf der nächstjährigen
landtagswahlen sich anzuschauen die csu
war nämlich bereit in den
koalitionsverhandlungen
sämtliche wahlversprechen abzugeben das
ist weil dieser gesamten
nachberichterstattung völlig
untergegangen weil sich der fokus auf
die fdp gelegt hat wenn wir
zurückschauen war seehofer beide csu
bereit zwei gehörige wahlversprechen
aufzugeben und das war eine obergrenze
für flüchtlinge von 200.000 die sind
einfach vom tisch gefegt und sichere
grenzen auch die wurden aufgegeben
und das sollte sich vor allen dingen der
wähler in bayern ganz genau merken gut 4
und herzlichen dank im schönen tag